and finally new rule with Mother's Day
and Father's Day coming up we all must
agree that the best gift an American kid
can give his parents is to sit them down
and say mom dad we need some space now
it's true I never had kids but maybe
that gives me some objectivity and what
I see in the generation coming up is
these kids are more anxious than a
squirrel on crystal meth and that's not
because the kids have changed it's
because the parents have they're called
helicopter parents because they're
always hovering too protective to always
on the case to always just there now if
we can only get them to work for the
Secret Service
so this topic has been much in the news
lately because there are now families
going against the grain who want to
raise their children guided by the
radical concept of occasionally letting
them out of their sight a movement that
has been dubbed free-range parenting or
as we used to call it
parenting actually we didn't even call
it that because parenting wasn't a word
because being a parent was in a job
description in the 70s parenting meant
you woke up went to your kids room if
they were alive you were done for the
day
crib monitors why what are they gonna do
turn into werewolves in the middle of
the light but that's not how most
parents see it these days and there have
been cases of free-range parents running
up against the law a couple in Silver
Spring Maryland has twice had their kids
ten and six picked up by the cops for
walking home alone from the park which
is all of two blocks away jeez I walked
farther than that to school every day
when I was a kid that agent nobody cared
in fact my mother always looked a little
disappointed when I came back
I mean what kind of country do we live
in were the sight of a kid walking alone
in his own neighborhood requires a call
to 911 being chased by a clown with his
dick out
then shut up and go back to watching
Judge Judy we're talking about Silver
Spring Maryland is not that perilous
most dangerous thing out in the fresh
air is probably the fresh air when did
we get this idea that children should
never endure even the slightest risk or
experience any disappointment if the ice
cream truck doesn't come the parents
panic and double strap the kids in the
car and rushed over to Baskin Robbins
where they disinfect the table and test
the cones for glutton fun and for what a
new study confirms that all this excess
time with kids is not having a positive
effect kids free to engage the world on
their own a bit wind up coming out
happier and more creative than the ones
who have to put on a helmet to take out
the garbage let the little bastards
breathe a little do you know that
American kids now spend 90% of their
leisure time at home plopped on the
couch watching TV playing video games
we're not raising citizens were
fattening veal cab and all because we
think outside is where the baby
Snatchers are and inside is where it's
safe right inside with the pornography
is at their fingertips 24/7 I have news
for you
that's the thing that's gonna really
[ __ ] them up for the rest of their lives
when I was a kid it was a thrill to find
an old Playboy in the neighbor's garage
but now every 10 year olds can whip out
his phone and in seconds we lookin at a
team of Japanese businessmen ejaculating
on a squid
that doesn't convince you parents
nothing well
you